[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليالي الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
ازمه الوثائق المسربه تتفاعل المسرب جنديف
استخبارات الحرس الوطني الامريكي والسلطات
تسعى لاعتقاله
اللجنه الرباعيه تعقد الاجتماعين منفصلين
مع البرهان واحمد لاحتواء الازمه في
السودان
[تصفيق]
عشيه القرار الحاسم للمجلس الدستوري
احتجاجات حاشده في فرنسا ونحو نصف مليون
متظاهر في باريس
الحرم المكي يشهد اكثر من مليون ومئه الف
مصلن وزائر خلال ثاني ايام العشر الاواخر
من رمضان
[موسيقى]
افادت مشاهدينا وسائل اعلام امريكيه
بمحاصره منزل المشتبه به في قضيه تسريب
وثائق الكونغرس بعد عاصفه من الجدل والقلق
اثرتها تسريب هذه الوثائق السريه للغايه
وكانت واحده من اكبر الكوابيس الدبلوماسيه
والامنيه لواشنطن مؤخرا لكن المفاجاه
الاكبر هنا هي ان مسرب وثائق البنتاجون
مجرد شاب عشريني غاضب بدا مشوار مسرب
وثائق البنتاجون المعروف بلقب اوجي عبر
منصه للالعاب الالكترونيه برفقه 20 من
رفاقه ممن يؤمنون بنظريه المؤامره حسب
طبعا ما كشفه تقرير امريكي عن هذا الشاب
هذا المسرب الشاب مشاهدينا مولع بالاسلحه
الناريه وكان يعمل في قاعده عسكريه وذلك
نقلا عن زملائه في مجموعه دردشه على
الانترنت وفقا هنا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست
الامريكيه نشر المسرب الوثائق وثائق
البنتاجون جزءا من هذه الملفات الحساسه
العام الماضي وقال لزملائه في المجموعه
انه حصل عليها خلال عمله في قاعده عسكريه
لم يحددها تلاها بعد هذه العمليه نشر مئات
الرسائل طوال اشهر منها مقتطفات
استخباراتيه سريه وتضمنت الوثائق المنشوره
معلومات عن مكان وتحركات قاده سياسيين
رفيعي المستوى وتحديثات تكتيكيه عن القوات
العسكريه وتحليلات جيو سياسيه وتحليلات عن
جهود الحكومات الاجنبيه للتدخل في نتائج
الانتخابات وما هي الا جزء صغير جدا من
سيل الاسرار فكان يخطط لنشر المئات منها
هنا السلطات الامريكيه والبنتاجون اطلقت
تحقيقا خاصا ادى للوصول لبعض الخيوط التي
قد تساعد في القاء القبض على مسرب الوث
ائق منها طبعا مقطع فيديو له
ظهر في خلفيته بعض الصور والادله التي
يمكن للمحققين استخدامها في اجراءاتهم مثل
اثاث واغراض وغيرها ما ظهر طبعا بهذا
الفيديو
[موسيقى]
في الفتره الماضيه وهي كانت طبعا على
مراحل تحدثت عن الحرب الاوكرانيه عن مسار
العمليات العسكريه عن حلفاء الولايات
المتحده عن تجسس عمليات تجسس التي يقوم
بها تقوم بها السلطات الامريكيه على
الرئيس الامريكي وعلى غيره من الحلفاء
وطبعا منذ حوالي الاسبوع وردود الفعل حول
هذه الوثائق لم تهدا ان كان من الجانب
الروسي من الجانب الاوكراني وطبعا من
حلفاء للولايات المتحده منها فرنسا وغيرها
التي اثبتت هذه الوثائق ضلوعها في هذه
الحرب بعدما كانت طيله يعني بدا هذه الحرب
ضلوع المباشر في ساحه المعركه وعلى الارض
مما يعني من تعزيز الذريعه الروسيه والتي
تقول بانهم يقاتلون الناتو وليس فقط
اوكرانيا
هذا وافادت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه بان
مسرب وثائق البانتاجون السريه هو جوندي في
استخبارات الحرس الوطني واوضحت صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز ان الشاب يدعى جاك تكسيرا
ويبلغ من العمر 21 عاما فيما نقلت صحيفه
مع مجموعه عبر الانترنت في منصه ديسكورد
وتضم نحو 30 مستخدما الذين قاموا بدورهم
بالتداولها مره اخرى على قنوات في تطبيق
تيليجرام لتنتشر بعد ذلك على مدى اوسع
عالميا
للحديث عن اخر هذه التطورات ينضم الينا من
واشنطن احسان الطوب مراسل العربيه حسين
يعني اخر ما تحدثت عنه السلطات الرسميه
هناك والتحقيقات معك تفضل
تحيه لك ليال ما نعرفه حتى الان بان الاف
بي اي داهم منزل
سانتقل الى المؤتمر الصحفي في البندكون
ونعود
كيفما خص المشترك به المحتمل في
التحقيقات وزاره العدل المستمره في
الافصاح غير المخول به الوثائق
لان هذه تحقيقات اجراميه مستمره فيجب ان
يحيلكم الى وزاره العدل اسئله
هي مساله خاصه بجهات انفاذ القانون ومن
غير مناسب لي او اي مسؤول وزاره الدفاع
التعليق في هذه اللحظات خاصه
وبعد ان معلومات وزاره العدد سوف نحيطكم
بها كما اشار وزير استون بان وزاره العدل
هي التي تاخذ هذه المساله الجديه ونستمر
بالعمل على مدار الساعه على جانب الوكاله
الداخليه والمجتمع
استخباراتي لفهمي عمق واثري هذه التسريبات
ونحن قائدنا بما نستطيع ان نقول فيما يخص
التحقيقات وزاره العدل المستمر ونحن ايضا
محددون بما استطع ان نقوله هو حول اي من
الوثائق نفسها ونحن نتفهم واهتمام الاعلام
الاسئله حول محتوى هذه الوثائق ولكننا
ودون نشير ان هذه سياسه مستمره لان
المعلومات السريه اذا
طرحت عبر الانترنت فهذا لا يعني بانها بعد
تغير السريه
مناقشه هي المساله ذات المساله الخاصه
بالمسائل الدفاعيه وسيسافر من هناك الى
المانيا هو وجنرال ميليسي يستضيف ثاني
اجتماعا في الحادي وعشرين من ابريل في
مجموعه اتصال الخاصه باوكرانيا وهذا هو
الاجتماع الحادي عشر لهذه المجموعه منذ
تاسيسها من قبل عام من الان
مشاهدينا نكتفي بهذا القدر للمؤتمر الصحفي
من البانتاجون اعود اليك حسين استمعنا
واياك لما قاله المسؤول الامريكي يعني هذه
التصريحات مع كل مسار التصريحات بالساعات
الماضيه معك تفضل
تحيه لك العيال مره جديده طبعا هذا
التصريحات تدل على مدى الجديه كما قال
المتحدث باسم جديه هذه الوثائق وكيف
يتعامل معها البانتاجون وايضا المسؤولون
الامريكيون ليروا الى اي مدى تؤثر هذه
الوثائق المسربه على العلاقات الامريكيه
وعلى بعض المعلومات الاستخباراتيه خاصه
فيما يخص الحرب في اوكرانيا بطبيعه الحال
حسب ما فهمنا ايضا بان الاف بي اي داهموا
منزل
نعم ولكنهم لم يقبضوا لم يلقوا القبض عليه
حتى الان هم ما زال البحث جاري عنه بطبيعه
الحال عندما يلقى القبض عليه هناك العديد
من الاسئله وهناك العديد من الامور يجب ان
تعرف كيف بالنسبه للصحافيين بالنسبه
للمشاهدين كيف استطاع هذا الرجل الوصول
الى هذا الكنز من
المعلومات خاصه بعد اتخاذ
استخبارات الامريكيه اجراءات عده عقبه
تسريبات ويكيليكس هناك اجراءات مشدده
اتخذت في الاماكن الحساسه في الولايات
المتحده نتحدث عن
لكي يتجنبوا وقوع حادثه مثل حادثه تسريب
لوثائق مهمه الان بعد عشر سنوات تقريبا
هناك تسريب ايضا خطير له تداعيات كما نعرف
على العديد من المناطق وعلى العديد من
القضايا الحساسه التي تتعامل معها
الولايات المتحده هناك اسئله كثيره هناك
ايضا تحقيق جنائي تقوم به وزاره العدل
اضافه الى التحقيق الذي يقوم بها
يعني ايضا السؤال سؤال الكبير الذي يطرح
كيف يمكن لاحد ليس بمنصب اصلا كبير او
بمكان يؤهله بان يكون له ولوج على هذا
الكم الهائل من الوثائق والتي تحمل طابع
سري جدا يعني هذا ايضا سؤال يطرا يطرح كيف
يمكن لاي احد ان يصل الى هكذا معلومات
هذا هو السؤال الاهم ربما ليال لان هذا
شاب في 21 من عمره يعني حتى
فعلوا
ما تسمى بالبحث الامني عن خلفيته الامنيه
لا يمكن ان يعطى هذا التصريح لكي يصل الى
هذه المعلومات الحساسيه التي يصل اليها
عاده
مسؤولون كبار لديهم خبره خبرات على الاقل
عشرات السنين ان كنا نتحدث في
مراكز الاستخبارات الامريكيه ان ياتي شباب
في 21 من عمره ويحصل على هذه المعلومات
هذا هذا خرق كبير هذا هذا يدل على ان هناك
مشكله في الاجراءات التي وضعت بعد تسريبات
ويكيليكس
ادت الى هذا التسريب الجديد هذا هو السؤال
المطروح بالفعل والذي يطرحه العديد من
الصحافيين ومن الخبراء كيف يمكن لهذا
الشاب الوافي 21 من عمره ان يصل الى هكذا
معلومات بعد كل هذه الاجراءات التي وضعت
طبعا كما قلنا هناك تحقيقات تجرى الان
هناك تحقيق جنائي من قبل وزاره العدل كل
هذه الامور مطالبه مطالب بها المسؤولين
الامريكيين لكي يقدموا اجابات عنها خاصه
في ظلت تصاعد المطالب ايضا في الكونجرس
الامريكي سمعنا رؤساء اللجان الاستخبارات
القوات المسلحه كنا نتحدث عن مجلس الشيوخ
ومجلس النواب تطالب
والاداره الامريكيه بتقديم اجابات وافيه
عن هذه التسريبات وهناك جلسات تدعى لعقدها
خلال الاسبوع المقبل لمسؤولين ليقدموا هذه
الاجابات للمشرع معك حسين يعني سير
التطورات ان كان بالتحقيقات او ان كان
بعمليه القاء القبض على هذا المجتمع شكرا
لك حسين التوت مراسل العربيه حدثنا من
واشنطن
هذا وكشفت وثائق لوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
عن خلافات عميقه تعصف باروقات الحكومه
الروسيه وكشفت الوثائق المسربه ان خلافات
شديده بين الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه
الروسيه حول الحرب في اوكرانيا بدوره رد
الكريم على مواصفها بتقارير اعلاميه ونفى
صحه هذه التقارير فلنتابع
وثائق تتسرب من داخل اروقه البنتاغون يسمع
صداها في موسكو الوثائق المسربه تزعم وجود
خلافات مستعره داخل اروقه الحكم الروسي
تقول الوثائق ان اقتتالا يبدو اعمق مما
عليه بين المخابرات الروسيه ووزاره الدفاع
وبحسب التسريبات فان جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
يتهم وزاره الدفاع بالتعتيم على حجم
الخسائر في اوكرانيا والاحجام عن نقل
الحقائق الى اعلى الهرم
تشير تقديرات الاستخبارات الروسيه الا ان
عدد القتلى والجرحى الروس وصل الى 110 الف
عنصر حتى فبراير الماضي
غير ان ارقام وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لا
تشمل ضحايا الحرس الوطني او عناصر فايكنر
او المقاتلين الشيشان الوثائق كشفت ايضا
اعتقاد المخابرات الروسيه بان قوات بلادها
المتنوعه المنتشره في اوكرانيا تصرفت
احيانا وفق اهداف متعارضه ما زاد من تعقيد
الجهود العسكريه الروسيه تقول نيويورك
تايمز ان التسريبات الاخيره تكشف عمق
الاختراق الامريكي للحكومه الروسيه بشكل
شبه تامن تقريبا كما تظهر ان خرق
الاستخبارات الامريكيه يمكن ان يحتوي على
مواد اكثر بكثير
الكرملين بدوره نفم وصفها بتقارير وانبات
تداولتها وسائل اعلام غربيه حول ذلك
الصراع بين اجهزته الامنيه والعسكريه
الناطق باسم الكرملين شكك في مصداقيه تلك
الوثائق وفي استيعاب القائمين عليها لجوهر
ما يحدث داخل روسيا على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
ازمه قديمه متجدده تستمر في السودان
خلافات خرجت للعلن بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع واتفاق تاجيل التوقيع عليه منذ
بدايه الشهر فيما يجري خلال هاتين
الساعتين اجتماعا منفصلان للجنه الرباعيه
مع اقطاب الازمه لاحتوائها طبعا هذا
مشاهدينا اذا الملف السوداني الذي سنتابعه
[موسيقى]
افادت مراسله العربيه في السودان بان مجلس
الامن والدفاع السوداني لن يعقد اجتماعا
اليوم على خلفيه احداث مروي في شمال
الخرطوم كما ان اللجنه الرباعيه ستعقد
اجتماعيا منفصلين لتهدئه مع رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي في السودان عبد الفتاح
البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان دقلو
هذا ويعيش السودان حاله من التوتر جراء
حشد قوات الدعم السريع قوات بمحيط القائد
الجويه في مراووي الشماليه البلاد حيث
تسعى القوى السياسيه والمدنيه لتدارك
الموقف قبل انزلاقه الى دوامه من العنف
في الولايه الشماليه بالسودان تحديدا في
مدينه مروي يبدو المشهد متوترا وقد ياخذ
البلاد الى هويه العنف عقب الحشود الاخيره
لقوات الدعم السريع التي قبلها الجيش
بتحرك مماثل المدينه الواقعه على الضفه
الجنوبيه للنهر النيل تحتوي على مطار دولي
واحدى اهم القواعد الجويه للجيش السوداني
التوتر الذي تشهده المدينه جاء بعد حشد
قوات الدعم السريع قرابه 100 اليه عسكريه
تحديدا في محيط القاعده الجويه جنوب
المدينه امر دفع الجيش السوداني الى تحشيد
قواته في القاعده الجويه ومحيطها
الجيش السوداني اعتبر تحرك الدعم السريع
مخالفا للقانون ويضع البلاد في منعطف وصفه
بالخطير والتاريخ الى السيما انه جرى دون
موافقته هذه الانفتاحات واعاده تمركز
القوات
يخالف مهام ونظام عمل قوات الدعم السريع
تقول المعلومات ان القوات الدعم السريعه
تريد الانقضاض على المطار العسكري الاهم
للجيش في الشمال لافشال اي تحرك جوي للجيش
وعبر سلاح الطيران اذا وقعت المواجهه منذ
مطلع الشهر الجاري بدا الجيش ببناء السور
ومرافق في الارض المحاذيه لمطار المدينه
امر قد يفسر سبب تحرك قوات الدعم السريع
التي يقودها حميدتي ومع توارد الانباء عما
تشهده ماوي بدات القوى السياسيه والمدنيه
تحركات المكوكيه لاحتواء الموقف موقف وصف
بالخطير ووصل مرحله ما قبل الط لقه الاولى
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من الخرطوم رئيس
تحرير صحيفه التيار عثمان مدني استاذ
عثمان يعني الخلاف العسكري العسكري الذي
مرغني عفوا الخلاف العسكري العسكري الذي
اخر التوقيع على الاتفاق السياسي والذي
يعني استمهل لايجاد ارضيه مشتركه اليوم
الخلاف الاساسي هو على عمليه الدمج ما
يحصل من حوار بين الطرفين هل ممكن ان يعني
يحل هذا التوتر الحاصل على الارض او ممكن
ان تتطور بالساعات المقبله
على الاتفاق بسبب هذا التفصيل لماذا تطورت
الامور الى يعني مواجهه حتى لو لم تتطور
الى مواجهه مباشره على الارض ولكن هناك
احتقان حقيقي بين الطرفين على الارض اليوم
نعم يعني الان هذه التطورات الاخيره تكشف
ان الخلافه السابقه حول مده دمج الدعم
السريع في الجيش السوداني لم يكن هو خلافا
حقيقيا او لم يكن هو السبب الاساسي عمليه
تلك القضيه قضيه فنيه كان من الممكن ان
يستمر الحوار حولها بين الطرفين يعني هي
لا تحتاج الى الى
تعبئه المدافع ومواجهه بعض يعني هي قضيه
يمكن ان تناقش خلف الابواب المغلقه بين
الطرفين طالما انها هي قضيه عسكريه فنيه
لكن واضح تماما ان تلك القضيه لم تكن هي
القضيه الاساسيه القضيه الاساسيه هي خلاف
في وجهات النظر حول العمليه العسكريه
العمليه السياسيه التي ستفضي الى تنازل
السلطه العسكريه من السلطه الان والخروج
من القصر الجمهوري واحلالها بحكومه مدنيه
كامله يبدو ان الخلافه الاساسي في مستقبل
العمليه السياسيه بمعنى اخر ليس قضيه
القضيه المعلقه حول الدمجه قوات الدعم
السريع في جيش السوداني بقدر ما هي مستقبل
العمليه السياسيه التي ستفضي الى واقع
جريده الواقع الجديد وخروج العسكر من
المشهد السياسي عثماني يعني هذه العمليه
السي اتت نتيجه تحرك شعبي عبر اللجان
وغيرها ونتيجه دعم دولي للعمليه السياسيه
وللعمليه الانتقاليه اليوم مع هذا
الاحتقان العسكري وهذه المواجهه العسكريه
كيف يمكن ان يصبح المشهد في الايام
والاسابيع المقبله في حال لم يعني توجد
ارضيه لحل داخلي مشترك
نعم يعني هذه المساله الان ليست في كنف
الايام هي مساله ساعات اذا لم تحل هذه
المساله خلال ساعات قليله فان السيناريو
الاخطر الذي لا يتمناه احد قد يكون هو
الواقع في الارض بمعنى ان هذه التوترات
بين الطرفين العسكريين على خلفيات الخلافه
السياسي حول العمليه السياسيه سينزلق الى
مواجهه قد تكون هذه المواجهه ربما تستغرق
فتره طويله ربما تغير من خارطه السياسيه
بصوره عامه وتنهي العمليه السياسيه
وتستبدلها باي حكم اخر كل ذلك سيكون قبضه
الجيش والمكون العسكري مجددا
نعم يعني هو بالعكس هو فعلا يعني اي خلاف
بين طرفين سيمدد من العمر السلطه العسكريه
بل حتى اذا استمر الوضع عليه الان دون ان
يكون هناك اشتباكات انا ذلك عمليا ان
العمليه السياسيه لن تنجح في احلالها
بحكومه مدنيه خلال القريب المنظور شكرا لك
استاذ عثمان على هذه المداخله
اثارت قاعده مروا الجويه خلافا بين
المكونات العسكريه المختلفه المتمثله
بالقوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الرد
السريع فلنتابع
قاعده مروي الجويه قد تفجر الصراع مجددا
في السودان بين المكونات العسكريه
المختلفه اهالي مروي تفاجئوا بعشرات
المركبات العسكريه التابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع تنتشر في مدينتهم وتطوق المطار
تظاهر رفضا لما جرى وتاييدا للقوات
المسلحه واعاده تمركز القوات
يخالف مهام نظام عمل قوات الدعم السريع
وفيه تجاوز واضح
للقانون ومخالفه لتوجيهات لجان الامنيه
المركزيه والولائيه
واستمرارها سيؤدي حتما الى المزيد من
الانقسامات والتوترات التي ربما تقود الى
انفراط عرض الامن بالبلاد
موقف القوات المسلحه نفته قوات الدعم
السريع وصفه تحركاتها بالطبيعيه والتي تم
تنسيقها مع قياده القوات المسلحه ضمن
تاديه مهامها وواجباتها
سبق لقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقل ان وعد بحل الخلافه مع الجيش والذهاب
الانتخابات النزيهه
الكعبه الشعب السوداني ان شاء الله جاب
لنا
لم تجار الانتخابات بل واجل توقيع على
اتفاق السياسي النهائي بين الاطراف
السياسيه لاجل غير مسمى فالاطراف العسكريه
لم تتفق ولم تدمج قوات الدعم السريع في
صفوف الجيش تقدر اعداد قوات الدعم السريع
بالالاف بدات تتشكل عام 2003 اسست رسميا
عام 2013 وتعمل تحت التسلسل قيادي بموجب
قانون خاص
[موسيقى]
تشهد شوارع العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
مواجهات بين الشرطه والمحتاجين على خلفيه
رفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما
حيث تقدر النقابات عدد المحتجين على قانون
التقاعد بنحو 400 الف في باريس وحده ودعا
هنا الفرنسيون الى الاضراب والتظاهر ضد
اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي يعد الثاني عشر
في ثلاثه اشهر عشيه طبعا قرار حاسم للمجلس
الدستوري بشان هذا المشروع من هولندا اكد
بان هذا القرار يمكن ان يغلق طريقا ويوضح
كل الاسئله المطروحه قبل ان يعلن انه
سيقترح بروح توافقيه لقاء مع الشركاء
الاجتماعيين يذكر انه منذ بدايه الازمه
يراوح الحوار مع النقابات مكانه هو جرت
المحادثات في اجواء من التوتر في الاسابيع
الاخيره بين كل من رئيس الدوله وقاده
النقابات لاسيما رئيس الاتحاد الديمقراطي
الفرنسي للعمل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
برر المتحدث باسم الحكومه الفرنسيه حظر
التجمعات حول المجلس الدستوريه ومجموعه
والذي من المقرر اصداره في وقت لاحق لتجنب
الضغط فلنستمع الى بقاله
قررت رئيسه الوزراء بنفسها احاله المساله
الى المجلس الدستوري وهو سلطه مستقله
ستخبرنا ما اذا كان مشروع القانون متوافقا
مع الدستور وهكذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه
المسار الديمقراطي من الواضح اننا نبحث عن
التهدئه والحوار
[موسيقى]
اصلاح قانون التقاعد الفرنسيه الذي اثار
عده موجات من الاحتجاجات يصل الى مرحله
حاسمه حيث تتم مناقشته في المجلس الدستوري
الذي سيقرر مدى دستوريه القانون فما هو
هذا الاصلاح فلنتابعه
تغيير نظام التقاعد الفرنسي رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
جاء في ظل ازمه يعيشها صندوق التقاعد قد
تصل الى 17 مليار يورو بحلول 2005
تظاهر الملايين من الفرنسيين ضد هذا
القانون خلال الشهور الاخيره
البرلمان الفرنسي لم يدعم المشروع وخاصه
احزاب اليسار
رئيسه الوزراء اليزابيث مررت القانون
باستخدام بند في الدستور معروف تحت رقم 49
ثلاثه
الشارع الفرنسي رد على القرار الحكومي
باضرابات في قطاعات حيويه
وبمظاهرات اكبر تخللت بعضها اعمال عنف
شاركت في التظاهرات قطاعات التعليم
والنظافه والنفط والنقل الجوي والبري
[موسيقى]
نا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الدفاع الروسيه تعلن ان قوه فادنير مستمره
في ضرب طرد القوات الاوكرانيه خارج مخمود
وكيف تنشر فيديو لجنودها في المدينه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اعود الى المؤتمر الصحفي
لعمليه تسريبات
في منطقه كردستان من العراق بالقرب من
السليمانيه
القوات الامريكيه المتواجده العراقي
وسوريا لدعم قواتنا الشركه المحليه ولد
دعم
مهمات هزيمتي 11
في هذه الحادثه
وان الضربه الجويه
عاد قسمت على بعد 100 متر من الرتل
والقياده المركزيه تحقق في الحادثه فاحيلك
الى القياده المركزيه ما هي مهمه الافراد
الامريكيين وهل كانت مسموعه قبل الحكومه
العراقيه
لهزيمه داعش هل هي خولات من الحكومه مخوله
من الحكومه العراقيه نحن ندعم القوات
الامنيه العراقيه كجزء مهمتي
هزيمه داعش كما تعرفون الذين قوات في
العراقيه لا تشن عمليات قتاليه هم يوفرون
النصر والمشهوره للقوات العراقيه اريدنا
القوات في سوريا ايضا تدعم قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه اذا مشاهدينا سنعود الى
المؤتمر الصحفي بعد قليل ولكن
بالعواجه التي وردت من هذا المؤتمر قبل
قليل بانه تم القاء القبض على احد المشتبه
بهم بعمليه تسريب وثائق البنتاجون التي
تعتبر عمليه التسريب الاوسع منذ سنوات
وعقود والتي طبعا سببت احراج كبير
للولايات المتحده مع حلفائها في الخارج
ايضا للتذكير بان المشتبه به الاساسي هو
شاب عشريني وكان يعمل في قاعده عسكريه
[موسيقى]
خطوه وبيان تاريخي من بكين بالاعلان عن
توافق سعودي ايراني على استئناف العلاقات
بين البلدين بعد سبع سنوات من القطيعه خطا
اول خطواته في العاشر من مارس الماضي
ثلاثها خطوات متسارعه عبر اتصالات متبادله
بين وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ونظيره الايراني الامير حسين عبد
الله تمهيدا لاول لقاء بينهما في السادس
من ابريل الجاري كانت العاصمه الصينيه في
الواجهه مجددا بعد استضافتها لقاء بين
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه ونظيره الايراني
نتج عنه طبعا بيان مشترك شمل بحث استئناف
الرحلات الجويه وتسهيل منح التاشيرات
وكذلك بدء ترتيبات اعاده فتح السفرتين
والقنصليات بين البلدين اما في الثامن من
شهر ابريل الجاري زار فريق فني سعودي
العاصمه الايرانيه طهران بحث هذا الفريق
اليات اعاده فتح السفاره السعوديه في
طهران والقنصليه في مشهد في خطوه اخرى نحو
تنفيذ بن ود الاتفاق الثلاثي الذي وصف
بالمفاجئ والتاريخي قبل ان تشهد امس
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض زياره وفد من
طهران لاتخاذ التدريبات طبعا اللازمه لفتح
سفاره ايران في الرياض وقنصلياتها في جده
اضافه الى بحث استئناف نشاط الممثلين
الايرانيه الدائمه في منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوات فاجنر
مستمره في طرد القوات الاوكرانيه خارج
التجمعات الرئيسيه في محمود قوات فاجن
الروسيه كانت قد اعلنت انها استولت على
اكثر من 80% من المدينه في حين نفل جيش
الاوكراني ذلك مؤكدا انه استعاد السيطره
على اكثر من 20% في شرقي المدينه
من جهه اعلن المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه
تنفيذ قوات فاجنر عمليات قتاليه مكثفه
لطرد القوات الاوكرانيه من مدينه
بحسب التسميه الروسيه للمدينه
في اتجاه دونيتسك واصلت قوه فاغنر
الهجوميه عمليات قتاليه عاليه الكثافه
لطرد العدو من الاحياء المركزيه لمدينه
ارتيموس فيما تقدم القوات المحموله جوا
الدعم لتقدم القوات المهاجمه وعرقله نقل
احتياطات الجيش الاوكراني الى المدينه
وامكانيه انسحاب وحدات العدو من هناك
بدوره اكد نائب رئيس وحدات العمليات
الرئيسيه في هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الاوكرانيه اوليكس ريموف ان الجيش الروسي
واصل عملياته الهجوميه في وسط مدينه ضخمه
مازال اتجاه بخموت هو الاتجاه الاصعب حيث
يواصل العدو عملياته الهجوميه في وسط
مدينه وكذلك في اتجاه بهدانكا لتطويق
المدينه من الشمال ايضا ولتعزيز
الامكانيات الهجوميه وتم بالفعل نقل جزء
من القوات والمعدات العسكريه للروس من
اتجاه اكتافكا الى منطقه باخموت
[موسيقى]
نعد مشاهدينا الى ملف تسريب الوثائق والى
عمليه القبض على المشتبه به واعود مجددا
الى الزميل حسين العربيه في واشنطن حسين
اخر التحديثات حول هذا الملف خصوصا انه
يعني العواجل تشير الى القاء القبض على
المجتمع بمن هو يعني مال المتوقع بساعات
المقبله
تحيه لك ليال بالفعل تم القبض على جاك
تيتشيرا في ولايه مصر
والان من المتوقع ان يتم احضاره الى
واشنطن حيث سيتم التحقيق معه هو ايضا
توجيه التهم له كما قال البانتاجون هو
يتعامل مع هذه العمليه بجديه كبيره
لحساسيه الموضوع
نتوقع في الساعات القريبه بعدما
قضاء القبض عليه كما راينا على الشاشات ان
يحضر الى هنا الى واشنطن لبدء هذه
الاجراءات هناك العديد من التهم نذكر بان
وزاره العدل ايضا تشارك في هذه التحقيقات
الجنائيه كما تصفها
تحقيق حول كيفيه وقوع هذا التسريب خاصه
بعد البروتوكولات العده التي وضعها اثر
وثائق ويكيليكس منذ نحو عشر سنوات هناك
اسئله كثيره الان عن كيفيه توصل هذا الشاب
الذي يبلغ من العمر 21 عاما الى هذه هناك
الكثير من الاسئله المطروحه هناك الكثير
من التحقيقات ايضا والمسؤولون الامريكيون
يحاولون معرفه مدى تاثير هذه التسريبات
على العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها وايضا على موضوع اسمح لي لو سمحت
عذرا على المقاطعه ان اشير الى اننا الان
نشاهد على الشاشه الصور الاوليه نقلا عن
قناه سي ان ان الامريكيه لعمليات القاء
القبض على المشتبه به طبعا قوات عسكريه
امريكيه تقوم بهذه العمليه نظرا لحساسيه
هذا الملف
وبعد ما تبعنا وشاهدنا الصور الاوليه قبل
قليل عن عمليه محاصره منزل المشتبه به هذه
الصور التي نقلتها قناه سي ان ان قبل قليل
عن عمليه القاء القبض على المشتبه به اعود
اليك حسين
[موسيقى]
كان احد المسؤولين في الكونغرس الامريكي
وهو رئيس لجنه الاستخبارات في مجلس الشيوخ
اشار الى ان العمليه ترقى العمليه التجسس
ولكن لا يمكننا طبعا ان نصدر الاحكام حتى
يتم التحقيقات ولكن هناك من يشير فيها
الولايات المتحده في الاحتمال ان تكون هذه
القضيه التجسس بينما يقول البعض انها فقط
تسريبات
تم وضعها ولم يتم الالتزام بها ابقى معنا
لو سمحت ساعود اليك الان سينضم الينا من
واشنطن ايضا
الاستاذ وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه استاذ وليد يعني
المفاجاه هي يعني هي ان يكون
المشتبه به شاب عشريني ليس بمركز كبير عمل
في قاعده عسكريه كيف وصل الى هذه المعطيات
والملفات التي تعتبر في غايه السريه
لقد نبهنا على قناتكم الكريمه منذ يومين
ان المشكله هي الان مشكله تنظيميه مؤسستيه
لم نكن نعرف بالطبع من هو هذا الشاب ولا
هويته ولكن عدد الذين يعملون في الجيش او
الاستخبارات او الاجهزه من العاملين
والاشخاص المرتبطين بهم او المتعاقدين
يعني مع الدوله هو كبير جدا هذا العدد لا
يحصى بالعشرات ولا بالمئات ربما بالالاف
وبالطبع ليس من الضروري ان يكون من يسرب
هكذا معلومات في الصفوف العليا ولكن طبعا
التحقيقات
في غايه السريه الولوج الى ملفات اساسيه
اليوم تعتبر ملفات امن قومي بالنسبه يعني
للخارج الامريكي نتحدث عن الحرب
الاوكرانيه نتحدث عن العلاقه مع الحلفاء
الاساسيين هل يعني لاي متعاقد او متدرب
امكانيه الوصول الى هذه الملفات
لاشرح قليلا لانه طبعا هذا يطرح سؤال كبير
جدا هنالك شيء في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مؤسسه اسمها سكيورتي كليرنس
يعني تصريح امنيه يسمح لمئات وربما للالاف
ولكن بتدرج هنالك العاليه جدا المتوسطه
الخفيفه ولكن لا يجب ان نسبق التحقيقات
ولكن اعطي سيناريو واحد من يطبع او من
يهتم بنقل او يعني شراء معاملات صغيره
يقرا بامكانها ان يقرا او بامكانها ان يصل
الى هذا الملف ليس بالضروره ان يقرا هذا
سوف يفتح باب نقاش كبير في الكونجرس حول
موضوع التصريح الامني
موضوع التصريح الامني وموضوع الاجراءات
الامنيه التي اتخذت من بعد تسريبات
ويكيليكس قبل عقد من الزمن هل اليوم ما
حصل يعني اثبت بان كل ما اتخذ من اجراءات
ان كان اجراءات يعني امنيه غير مجديه
وهناك يعني يجب ان يكون هناك اعاده نظر
بكل هذه الاجراءات
هكذا قضيه بعد ان يتم التحقيق سوف ايضا
يتم تحقيق
يمول وهو يغير بالقوانين سوف تكون محطه
مهمه لانه هكذا حوادث قد حدثت في الماضي
ولكن حجم هذا الحادث في وضع دولي خطير
ودقيق جدا سوف بالطبع كما تفضلتي يفتح باب
اعاده ومراجعه الاجراءات السابقه
اعاده يعني ومراجعه الاجراءات السابقه بظل
الان
قسار اليوم بين
راتب الجمهوري هل ممكن ان يكون هناك عرقله
ام ان هناك يعني توجه واحد بهذا الموضوع
خصوصا اننا نتحدث عن ملفات امن قومي
بالنسبه للجانب الامريكي
دون شك هنالك توافق داخلي على الرغم من كل
الانقسامات يعني الانتقادات المتبادله
والحروب السياسيه التي نراها جميعا حتى من
خلال الاعلام طبعا هنالك جهاز يعني ضمن
الكونغرس لان الكونغرس سوف يكون معني
وبالطبع الاداره والبيروقراطيات سوف
يتعاطى مع هذا الموضوع اما ان يسيب
الموضوع فلا شك انه سوف يسير لا شك اننا
سوف نسمع كلاما من المعارضه اي جهه من
المعارضه لا اعلم ربما تذهب الى اعلى راس
المعارضه او الى الى اسفل قواعدها ستنتقد
الاداره على هذا الاداء وسوف ستستعمله في
المواجهات السياسيه وهذا ليس اول مره ولكن
عمليا الذين سوف يعملون على تشريعات جديده
هم متحدين يجب الدفاع عن امن القومي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ابقى معنا
استاذ وليد لو سمحت حتى اعود الى الزميل
لحسين التوت حسين يعني كنا نتحدث عن
الخطوات القانونيه اللاحقه بعد القاء
القبض على
المشتبه به ما هي اخر يعني التحديثات بهذا
الموضوع واخر التصريحات الرسميه لو سمحت
يعني اخر تصريحات هي ما سمعناها من
المتحدث باسم الذي شرح بان ما فعله
هو سرقه لهذه
الوثائق طبعا هناك علامات استفهام كثيره
حول دوافع هذا الشاب لماذا فعل ذلك هل هو
فعل ذلك من هل هو له علاقه باجهزه
استخبارات اجنبيه ام انه يريد الانتقام من
شيء او انه يؤمن بشيء هناك اسئله كثيره
هذه ستتبين الاجوبه عليها خلال التحقيقات
معه الامريكيون عاده
يقفزون الى الامام بتحليلاتهم
واستنتاجاتهم قبل ان يحققوا المتهم الاول
عندما يحققون معه ليتاكدوا اولا اذا كان
هناك بالفعل هو العلاقه مع اجهزه
استخبارات اجنبيه عند الموضوع عندها سيكون
هناك موضوع مختلف من موضوع اخطر عليه لانه
سيكون هناك التجسس وهناك قوانين بطبيعه
الحال تحرم وتمنع وبانه يريد لديه كاريزما
وك يريد ان يفرض نفسه كقائد للمجموعه هذا
ادم الموضوع الثاني ولكن بطبيعه الحال
بجميع الاحوال ما قام به بحسب المسؤولين
الامريكيين على راس المسؤوليه
اجراميه لان يحصل على معلومات لم يكن من
المفترض ان يحصل عليها وهو يعرف ذلك كما
قال المتحدث انه يعرف ان هذه المعلومات
كان يجب ان لا يطلع عليها واطلع عليها
واخذها وقام بنشرها ولكن ماذا سيجري بعد
ايامنا التحقيقات واسابيع واشهر ربما هذا
الموضوع سننتظر
التحقيقات لنعرف ما هو تقييم البانتاجون
وهو تقييم وزاره العدل لما جرى حسين اسمح
لي ان اناقش هذه النقطه مع دكتور وليد
فارس دكتور وليد يعني بما صدر من من حديث
اولي او تعليق اولي حول المشتبه به بانه
يؤمن بنظريه المؤامره هل اليوم من مصلحه
الجانب الامريكي في حال اثبته التحقيقات
يعني خرق امني لجهه معينه وخصوصا الجانب
الروسي بظل هذا
ظل حرب التضليل الموجوده بين الطرفين هل
يعني من مصلحته ان يكشف عن ذلك ام انها
ستبقى بمرحله الاضطراب النفسي وما الى ذلك
لا ندري التحقيقات سوف تقول لنا الكثير
ولكن هنالك السيناريوهات متعدده الاساس
هنا انه الاولاد تحت الامريكيه واطراف
عالميه هي في اجواء ملتهبه يعني لمن هذه
المعلومات تتعلق بالحرف في اوكرانيا هذا
امر خطير وكبير للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حتى ولو كان هذا الفرد لم يقصد
ما قام به
اكثر عوامل نفسيه لا نعرف هذا الموضوع
ولكن من بين تلك السيناريوهات اثنين
باعتقاد المحققين سوف يركزون عليها اولا
ما هو موجب او ما هو هي الاسباب التي
دفعته لكي يحصل على الوثائق هذا واحد
لانها بامكانها ان تكون شيئين تجسس كما
ترون في التقرير ولكن الت
جسس عن اذا هنا شك كبير هل توزيعها في
الاعلام هو مامور هو امر اتى لزعزعه الوضع
الداخلي الامريكي ام انه العمليه هي كانت
تجسس حصل على هذه المعلومات وبعد ذلك لم
يستحسن ان يرسلها الى من كلفه بها او ان
يكون هو
شخصيا كما تفضلتم في النشره يحاول ان يثبت
شخصيته امام مجموعه من الناس
بموضوع بموضوع يعني اذا كان الموضوع تجسس
ويجب ان يتم ارسال هذه الوثائق الى الجهه
المعنيه بذلك هنا ايضا يعني هناك حرب
دائره حرب المعلومات وحرب التضليل بين
الجانبين الامريكي والروسي وهي ليست
بالجديده يعني هي على مراحل متقطعه بان
كان بالتاريخ وان كان عبر الزمن اليوم نحن
امام مرحله مفصليه من الحرب بين الجانبين
اليس من مصلحه الطرف الاخر ان يكون يعني
هذه الفوضى ان تحصل للجانب الامريكي في
الداخل والخارج في حال ثبتت نظريه او
التحقيقات اثبتت موضوع التجسس
كلام
صحيح وم من الاحدث انه ضعيف الشخصيه تم
تحريكه من جهات خارجيه بالعلم انه اذا حصل
على هذه المعلومات هو سوف يفشيها
ويضعف موقف الامريكي هذا السيناريو
السيناريو الثاني هو عمليا ان تكون
العمليه كانت تهدف شيء واصبح فيها شيء اخر
وسناريو الثالث مثلا انه هدف الذين سمحوا
بهذا الامر قد يكون اعلى من رتبته لا نعرف
يعني قد يكون هذا الامر قد اعطيت هذه
المعلومات له دون ان يقال لهما يجب ان
يكون فيها وهو ضعيف النفسيه او شيء من هذا
النوع وبالتالي حصل ما حصل سيناريات
متعدده جدا جدا كما تفضلت
ابقى معنا استاذ وليد لو سمحت انتقل ايضا
الى واشنطن والمحلل السياسي ايهاب عباس
استاذ استاذ ايهاب يعني عمليه الارباك
التي حدثت في الداخل والخارج الامريكي بعد
تسريبات البنتاغون اليوم يتضح بان من كان
وراءها شاب عشريلي هذا يطرح الكثير من
الاسئله التي يعني طرحناها وناقشناها منذ
قليل ان كان مع الزملاء وان كان مع استاذ
وليد ما رايك بكل هذه الاسئله المطروحه
نعم اهلا بحضرتك وبكل الزملاء والضيوف وكل
المشاهدين اينما كانوا
طبعا انا انا
لم استمع لكل الاجابات ولا كل الاسئله
ولكن ربما
ستدور في نفس الاطار الذي ساجيب عنه هذا
الفتى الصغير يعني قام بمغامره كبرى ستكون
هي المغامره الاكبر في حياته والتي ربما
ستؤذيه طوال عمره خلال الفتره القادمه
قدم معلومات كثيره وقيمه وعلى طبق من ذهب
لاعداء الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولمنافسي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بل
وصنع بالبلد كبيره بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ودول حليفه لها
بل شرب معلومات كثيره
سانتقل الى مؤتمر لوزير العدل الامريكي
ونعود
وسوف نوفر لكم مزيد من المعلومات في الوقت
المناسب شكرا جزيلا لكم
انتهى المؤتمر الصحفي الذي طبعا يتحدث عن
التحقيقات وبانه لن يكون هناك اي يعني
توضيحات جديه قبل البدء بالتحقيقات وهو
المسار الطبيعي القانوني داخل الولايات
المتحده اعود اليك استاذ ايهاب يعني اليوم
التحقيقات مهما اثبتت ومهما كان الدافع
اليوم نتحدث عن خرق كبير لملفات وصفت
بغايه السريه بكم هائل هذا يفتح الكثير من
الاسئله حول النظام الامني النظام
المراقبه في الداخل وكيف يمكن ان تتجنب
واشنطن هذا الموضوع لاحقا
المشكله اليوم ان لدينا في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
عمليات بشكل متكرر ربما هذه ليست المره
الاولى بكل تاكيد ولكن هذه المره المشكله
انها جاءت بكم كبير جدا من التسريبات
والوثائق السريه
والهامه والغايه في السريه والمطلقه
بالامن القومي الامريكي وعلاقات
الاستراتيجيه مع عدد من دول العالم وطبعا
الملفات يعني ان كان للحرب وان كان لنظام
العالمي ككل
نعم وفي توقيت يعني هناك ملفات ثلاثه
تشغل بها الالويات المتحده الامريكيه بشكل
كبير جدا هذه الوثائق اتت عليها بشكل
مميز هذا التعبيرات طبعا الملف روسي
اوكرانيا ملف الصين ملف الشرق الاوسط وهذه
ملفات كبرى يعني تم تسريب بيانات كثيره
متعلقه بها اليوم هناك
ميزانيات تزداد في الدفاع الامريكيه
لتقديم الدفاعات اكثر سيبرانيه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ضد هذه الهجمات ودائما
ربما تستمعون كثيرا لعمليات اختراق
لوكالات فيدراليه امريكيه مختلفه
ويتم اتهام مخترقين روس
وقراصنه روس وصينيين وربما من جنسيات اخرى
بانهم قاموا بعمليات الاختراق لكن حجم
الاختراق هذه المره لم يكن من الخارج كان
من الداخل
وهناك ربما التحقيقات ستجلب بكل تاكيد مع
اوجي الفتى الذي اوقف القبض عليه بسبب هذه
التسريبات حول اذا ما كانت لديها علاقات
بالخارج اولى اذا ما كان هذه الوثائق تم
ارسالها الى اشخاص في الخارج ولم يتم
نشرها كلها يعني بكل تاكيد سيتم
التعامل مع هذا الفتى بحرص شديد جدا حتى
يتم استخراج كافه المعلومات الممكنه عما
حدث خاصه وان هذه التسريبات وهذه الوثائق
وحصل عليها خلال الفتره الماضيه خلال عملي
في احدى القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه فلديه
معلومات بالطبع كثيره جدا عن كيفيه اختراق
هذه
الاجهزه الكمبيطريه انجاز التعبير او
الغرف المغلقه التي يحتفظ بها في هذه
الوثائق وطبعا الى اين سربت ومن استفاد
منها يعني هناك اسئله كثيره ستطرح على هذا
الشاب نعم على كل حال يعني اللي استفاد
منها هم الاساسيين اليوم للولايات المتحده
اسمح لي استاذ ايهاب ان اعود الى استاذ
وليد فارس استاذ وليد فارس في حال ذهبنا
نحو النظريه الثانيه ليس نظريه الاضطراب
واثبات الشخصيه الى هناك مع انها موجوده
كثيرا داخل الولايات المتحده نظريه
الاختراق الخارجي عمليه احداث فوضى سياسيه
معلوماتيه استخباراتيه عسكريه داخليه
وخارجيه للولايات المتحده بهذا التوقيت
يستفيد منها يعني اليوم دولتين اساسيتين
الصين وطبعا روسيا كيف يعني ستؤثر على
الولايات المتحده بالفتره المقبله
لو سمحت لي فقط 10 ثواني لاطرح نظريه اخرى
ايضا تكون مرتبطه بالسيناريوهات بانتظار
نتائج تحقيقات وزاره العدل هنالك ايضا
احتمال ان يكون هذا العمل ليس فقط من
اضطراب نفسي او الى ما هنالك هنالك تيار
اساسا موجود داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو معارض بشراسه براديكاليه ضد
سياسه الاداره التي يطلقون عليها اسم
الجلوبال يعني العلاقه مع الحلف الاطلسي
ما يجري في اوكرانيا صرف الميزانيات الى
ما هنالك احتمالان هنا الاول ان يكون هو
شخصيا منتمي الى هكذا تيار وانا انا قد
قرات كثيرا عنه وعن يعني الكوادر التي
تعمل له في الانترنت وهذا شبيه جدا بما هو
قاله حتى الان او عمل به خلق فوضى ولكن من
المحتمل ايضا ان يكون هنالك تكون هنالك
خارجيه تجنب هكذا اشخاص دون ان يعلموا
يعني ترسل لهم المعلومات بهدف ان ينشره
هذه المعلومات ولكن على ما كانت عليه
السيناريوهات هذا الامر الان وفي هذه
الظروف
وقد سوف تخلق ازمه ليس فقط داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ولكن داخل الحلف اء
يعني تصور الاوكرانيين او جزء من العرب
ومصر ودول اخرى في المنطقه هذا يعني يباعد
الحلفاء او يحذرهم من الطعام فوضى داخليه
خارجيه احدثت ازمه ازمه ثقه بين الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها بتوقيت حساس جدا ان كان
من الحرب وان كان بعمليه يعني خلق
تحالفات جديده في العالم استاذ وليد ابقى
معي وايضا
حسين الزميل حسين التوضؤ استاذ ايهاب
ابقوا معي سانتقل الان اختم التاسعه
وانتقل الى 360 وزميل راويه راويه نكمل
معك هذه التغطيه تفضل لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات